A Quiet Place is a chilling but riveting film
that delivers a fresh twist on the horror
genre.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the ending to
A Quiet Place, plus explaining some details
you probably didn't know about the creatures
in the movie.
If this is your first time here, I do regular
movie breakdowns, so if you enjoy this video
be sure to subscribe for more.
Spoiler warning, I'll be discussing the whole
movie, so take care if you've not seen it
yet.
A Quiet Place is set in a near future in which
an alien invasion has decimated swathes of
the human population around the world.
The creatures have super-sensitive hearing
and so survivors like the Abbotts live as
quietly as possible.
This is why John Krasinski's character Lee
puts down sand trails to muffle sounds while
walking and everyday life has been completely
adapted to dampen any sound.
The monsters are blind, so visual signals
are an important way for the human characters
to communicate.
And because the family have a deaf daughter,
they have been able to use the American Sign
Language they learned with her to talk silently
with each other.
Ok, let's take a look at the alien creatures
and why they attack anything making a sound.
Design-wise the aliens are rather interesting
– they're different from but do bring to
mind other creatures like the Demogorgon in
Stranger Things, the xenomorph in the Alien
movies, the monster in Cloverfield, and the
crazy sharp teeth you see with Venom.
The film's production designer Jeffrey Beecroft
has said that he took inspiration for the
alien's form from a Nautilus shell.
The nautilus is a type of sea creature that
has very poor eyesight although A Quiet Place
dials that up, making the aliens completely
blind.
By the way, there are various newspaper clippings
which describe the aliens as either "Death
Angels" or "Angels of Death" which is interesting
because, in the Jewish tradition, the archangel
Samael is known as the angel of death and
is sometimes referred to as the "blind god"
as well.
And the aliens really do seem to be the bringers
of death, but Lee has been researching them
extensively and on his white board we can
see the main things he knows about them.
One thing he's still trying to figure out
is the answer to the question "Why don't they"
– I think that says – "eat their kill?"
Although the movie doesn't seem to touch on
this in an obvious manner, production designer
Jeffrey Beecroft has explained that "when
loud sound vibrates inside [the aliens' body],
it's intensely painful and they will destroy
anything that makes noise."
And we do see them pulsating and thrashing
around when they're faced with a big sound.
Which means the real reason why the creatures
attack anything making a loud noise isn't
for sport or for food – instead, it seems
like they're trying to eliminate [loud] sounds
in the environment around them.
And, of course, as the family eventually discovers,
although the aliens' hypersensitivity to sound
makes them deadly to life on earth, it's actually
their weakness as well.
And that makes Lee's efforts to develop a
working hearing aid for his daughter Regan,
played by Millicent Simmonds, the key to the
story.
The new hearing aid he gives her doesn't work
properly and creates a high-pitched sound
that is not only uncomfortable to her, but
is also unbearable to the creatures when they're
nearby.
It seems likely that because the aliens are
blind, they rely on a sort of echolocation,
or bio sonar to emit soundwaves that they
can track to navigate and hunt.
These soundwaves create audio feedback when
they hit the amplifiers in Regan's hearing
aid and, because of the creatures' audio hypersensitivity,
the amplified feedback sound ends up being
extremely painful for the aliens.
Now, when you watched the movie you may have
been hoping that Regan knew this when she
and her brother were hiding in the car as
it could have saved their father, but at that
moment she didn't understand that the hearing
aid's audio feedback was affecting the aliens.
When it happened the first earlier, the alien
was behind her in the corn field and although
we could hear the creature rustling, because
Regan is deaf, she had no idea it was behind
her – all she could feel was the uncomfortable
pitch from the feedback loop right by her
head.
And when Regan and her brother were in the
silo, although she also felt the feedback
she didn't realise that was the reason the
creature ran off.
It's not until Regan is in the basement with
her mother and they are confronted with an
alien that suddenly goes into an uncontrollable
spasm that Regan understands her hearing aid
has uncovered the monster's weakness.
But the feedback doesn't kill the creature
and it comes back at them.
However, its head is exposed as it opens up
so Evelyn kills it with a shotgun blast to
the face.
This leads us to the very final moment of
the movie where Evelyn and Regan realise what
they have to do.
As the remaining aliens come running to the
farmhouse attracted by the noise of the gun,
Regan and Evelyn have the hearing aid, speaker
and shotgun at the ready.
According to Lee's white board there should
be two creatures left in the area, so it should
be possible for them to take them both out.
The wider world might also recover if the
discovery can be relayed to others so that
sound-based weapons can be developed to take
down the alien invasion.
By the way, the idea of being pregnant during
this apocalyptic time is interesting both
in terms of the plot and for what it symbolises.
Obviously, it creates a huge problem as not
only is giving birth in total silence impossible,
but a new-born baby will also naturally cry
out.
To cope with this, the family builds a special
basement area with a box for the baby complete
with an oxygen tank.
The underground room is covered with a mattress
which seems to muffle sounds coming from below
enough to keep any creatures from detecting
them.
The birth was actually supposed to take place
in this room but, of course, Evelyn was forced
to give birth in the bathroom while she was
hiding from the alien invading the house.
Symbolically, Evelyn's pregnancy and birth
signals hope for their family and the future
of the world and you can also see this in
the fact that, despite their terrible situation,
Evelyn tries to move forward by home-schooling
her children and both parents try to maintain
their spirits with family dinners and board
games.
This indicates that the Abbot family is trying
to thrive, not just survive, during this nightmarish
time.
By the way, the scene where Evelyn is in the
flooded basement with the baby is an interesting
call-back to earlier in the film where Lee
showed his son Marcus how the sound of the
waterfall would mask noises they made.
The sound of the water in the flooding basement
muffled some of the sound of the whimpering
baby, but Evelyn took herself and the baby
behind a sheet of falling water as the baby
started to cry and just like with the waterfall,
the noise of the falling water was enough
to drown out the baby's crying.
So, did you enjoy A Quiet Place and what did
you think about the creatures?
Also, would you like to see follow-up stories
set in this universe, along the lines of the
Cloverfield movies?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments
below and you can also tweet me @Jan_Gilbert
or @FlicksCity.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that like button and sharing the video,
plus you can check out more of my breakdowns
and horror movie videos by tapping the screen
right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers.